would you like some french toast
yes please
what shape
square is fine all right
so what do you say we get started after
breakfast i'm full
so how you feeling about the new company
i feel good wow
you excited about the new company yeah
i'm excited to start the company after
breakfast
we did that
so what's next
michael just stop for a second michael
stop for a second
no i know you are just let me help you
just keep fine
oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry this is going to be a very
good year
very good
jane is at home jim is back
my protege ryan is a corporate
good stuff
um andy and dwight
are rocking the sales team i feel very
blessed
[Music]
everybody in the conference room
i don't care if you are gay or straight
or a lesbian or overweight just get in
here right now and the same thing goes
for quarterly reports they are
unreadable they're just numbers and
boring and black so what i was thinking
is that maybe we should have some sort
of graphic like if we have a bad quarter
put in a storm cloud
and
when we have a good quarter
fireworks
or
a race car
doesn't have to be a race car
use your imagination there's this cube
on the screen and it bounces around all
day and sometimes it looks like it's
heading right into the corner of the
screen and at the last minute hits a
wall and bounces away
and we are all just dying to see it go
right into the corner
pam claims that she saw it one day when
she was alone in the conference room
okay
i believe she'd think she saw it
i saw it i saw it and it was amazing who
said i didn't see it did jim say that i
didn't see it i saw it we have a lot of
colored paper here
why why do we keep printing this on
white no come on yeah
i know
i know it's bland it's never gonna
happen here's what i'm saying you gotta
believe
maybe
we could have some sort of riddle
wait for like
something that you have to look for
sort of a where's waldo
[Music]
all right all right
all right let's quit while we're ahead
that was so awesome that was awesome
thank you
some days i am just on fire
why don't i say
one uh asked you anything ever so
whoever's name is toby why don't you
take a letter opener and stick it in
your skull
dunder mifflin this is aaron
he's not available right now
uh-huh
yes
sure i'll give him the message when he
gets up gets back
michael had chicken pot pie for lunch
actually let me rephrase that michael
had an entire
chicken pot pie for lunch and
let me be more specific michael ate an
entire
family sized chicken pot pie for lunch
and then he promptly fell asleep so
we're all trying to be very quiet so as
to not wake him up before 5 pm which
actually should be in about
10 minutes
okay i'm gonna go in there and change
the computer are you sure you can change
this watch i can do it what do you need
from me
normally i don't condone leaving early
but i have an appointment with the horse
doctor
how that horse became a doctor i don't
know
[Laughter]
no i'm kidding he's just a regular
doctor who shoots your horse in the head
when his leg is broken
like clockwork
oh
[Laughter]
oh wow okay
all right let's all go home come on
see you all to molly
you later michael
thunder mifflin this is pam
oh hi jan
he's uh on a sales call no message
bye jan
that's interesting
wow it's a little early for ice cream
day it's never too early for ice cream
jim
but we didn't have any ice cream
so this is mayonnaise and black olives
oh it's comfort food all right
hope she didn't do anything to the food
like like what i can't prove it
but i think she might be trying to
poison me
hey looks great babe yeah it really does
i know jan didn't poison the food i know
that
but if she was going to poison the food
of someone at that table wouldn't it be
me
michael's former lover
do you want to do that
it's disgusting
you know i have soft teeth how could you
say that
oops
excuse me for a second
so
how do you guys know each other
i was this babysitter and now you guys
are dating
purely carnal that's all you need to
know
would you write down your email because
i have just
so many questions email
nevermind okay
all right
there we go
oh
okay that's nice everybody enjoying
their meal
okay let's get right into it i need two
people for the first scene ooh ooh ooh
mr katare mr katter
okay michael and
anybody
uh how about mary beth
come on
okay so you start us off mary beth
boom detective michael scarn i'm with
the fbi think about this what is the
most exciting thing that can happen on
tv or in movies or in real life
somebody has a gun
that's why i always start with a gun
because you can't top it you just can't
i'm supposed to meet my doctor here have
you seen him he's a very angry [ __ ]
boom freeze michael schoon fbi you know
what you did
boom boom boom
yeah you thought you could get away with
your little ruse didn't you didn't you
well you didn't because i know where you
hid the diamonds i've been on to you and
your little friends for weeks
i'm not even in the scene
they're not stopped boom okay she shot
me great stop why okay you can't just
shoot everyone in the scene well if you
hadn't stopped the scene you would have
seen where it was going okay what about
the scene they set up
boring no it wasn't no more guns no no
michael
once you give me all the guns you have
just get rid of all your guns and give
them to me
great
yeah okay
what a cute bench thanks that's my bed
jan has uh some space issues so i curl
up on that puppy
really cause
seems pretty narrow
and short it's actually a lot bigger
than it seems look at this
see
he fits perfectly
you